I follow him on Twitter and you should
go check him out on his tour dates at
the parks casino in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania on the 22nd of February and
then the Ocean Resort Casino and
beautiful lovely bucolic Atlantic City
New Jersey the day after he is none of
them Frank Caliendo yes I flew in
because I was gonna originally do
something else out here last night and
then it turned out that didn't happen so
I was just I didn't want to change the
date I wanted to stay I appreciate stay
true to you because thank you Frank it
was like a twofer
and for me a trip and I just went I've
got I'm trying not to go I've been
working on it I don't have it yet this
is a workshop day this is a workshop
more than happy to have the rejection
show be your work yeah that's fine work
my way it's worked my way up to Conan or
something is that don't believe I'm a
gateway show is this just as big and as
important as every I'm sure I got I got
Mariucci hands head you know rich what
is that what is that when he just he's
shooting the gap when every time he
starts to talk marry inches like we're
gonna tell his eyes get so big I don't
know where it happens it's like
headlights are coming at him and he's
just like rich we're gonna talk about
this for a second this is what's going
on somebody's coming in here Sunday it's
gonna be getting Michael Irvin's on this
up to Dallas Cowboys Dallas Cowboys
aren't even playing where you coming
from Bridge I haven't breathed for over
a half an hour right now what's going on
because if there is I'm sure what the
Saxon is exactly took a breath I feel
good about myself
and it's starting to happen I have done
absolutely 34 seconds and not set a
single thing rich you know he does and
you're doing it does God he mooches got
like quick [ __ ] what's going on the
screen rich there's a word ring went
down my hand I coach with everybody in
the league I'm part of the branch that
everybody knows the Mike Holmgren branch
John Gurda was there there's a branch
and I would extend it out
do you what a my eyeball just popped out
on a green screen we'll figure it out
we'll put it up I can't wait to marry it
you could be out there right now as a
matter Greer
Andrew Whitworth the interview was by
the way and and I say this with the
ultimate respect coming on the air after
you just had a great interview to talk
about how great the interview was that's
out of the Rome playbook phenomenal
right raise that if I had any breath
right now I would use it we want you to
come I worked I tried to work in a
Michael Irvin I had no idea what were
even talking about
but the Dallas Cowboys I crack myself up
[Laughter]
look at this I'd say you gotta get in
shape to do Mary oh yeah you learn that
with the ball is here Mary oh she keeps
in shape by eating copious amounts of
chicken parm is that what it is yeah
yeah so everybody in here because you
have Matthew McConaughey coming up we're
talking about doing a Matthew
McConaughey in pressure my god don't
really do it it turns into it's okay it
turns into Jerry Jones halfway through
we should call up the NFL office I got
that I know what we need to do robots
let's just call up the NFL offers like
robots we need robot officials that is
what they do there will be sensors all
around the playing surface and when they
say if a person or a player steps out of
bounds then we will be notified
at the Dallas Cowboys facility why the
Dallas Cowboys facility well you know
why because I am the reason that this
league is even part of the culture right
now but we will involve two cyborgs
we need sidewalks I believe that there
are side that's that's Matthew
McConaughey playing yes Jerry Jones
heard that I believe that way yeah
everything all right I found one that's
kind of working today and the word [ __ ]
which is why I'm not sure which no Mary
oh she was supposedly the good one now
you just called it you just said which
one is it and they're not even sure no
no you've been no it's a way which one
of you work shopping again I think
you've found out in your work shopping
Frank Caliendo that you need to you need
to bring it down get your cardio done
before you do the Mariucci no I'll bring
it down it's just like you gotta you
gotta you got to work on some breathing
exercises woody tell me Shawn McVeigh is
so close to John GRU there's no question
I see I don't hear it the same way cuz I
said Kate I hear Jon Gruden and he's
slow man he took he had me come out and
talk to the Raiders this year Gruden oh
yeah I went I wasn't up and work are
setting up their front they won the game
too so then he started calling me the
Raiders are coming you guys come out
again man we uh we got some good luck
Derek I'm gonna call Derek dc-dc Derek
it was like you pumped us up man it was
awesome I'll tell you what man so I'm
doing Gruden for a little bit he's over
the corner just going on man you gonna
move on to the next voice right like no
man you brought me in these guys are
enjoying this I'm just trying to find a
way to communicate how you gonna take
this one home man
but the Shawn McVeigh he's got the
McVeigh's got that he says he's he's
quicker to me he's got that dad day you
know he says you know he says you know
you know it's gonna be that kind of you
note you know it's like like a triple
you know I was trying to figure it out
now I'm too hyped up right now to even I
had to get it I'm going at full speed
that miria-chan slow myself down and see
that's the workshop
okay okay nope I don't have it I thought
McVeigh has the Gruden's Tings
you did got the Katyn and what's that
that is it's like you know what we're
gonna do is we're gonna come out we're
gonna play we're gonna cut and we're
gonna dominate we're we're gonna you
know damn uppity he's they're all
Muppets now where did that come from
that all these NFL people became Andrew
Luck sounds like he has a muppet stuck
in his throat what is that his teeth
line up perfectly and then Patrick
mahomes he's it's Bert and Ernie that's
what their homes is like you know these
guys are gonna character Fozzie Bear and
Kermit yeah he's a range of Muppets this
is fantastic
frankly under here on the Rich Eisen
show how would John Madden do you think
take Tony Romo's ability to call plays
beforehand like you know I look at him
and he's like big Tony Romo is the kind
of guy that he's getting plays from the
three-eyed Raven watch that show with
Khaleesi and you see the impression to
years old but the material is for Jason
and only say a couple words at a time
and figure out what's happening in the
play and I not sure what just happened
oh he's so excited he's excited as I'm
excited as me in this like interviewer
that something like his his brain isn't
catching up with his words like his
voice is going he's like right there did
you see what they did if they and the
play is over he's like one of the
sweetest guys by I think it's just I
think he hasn't I think he would
straight to the booth and I've asked her
out people said he's the nicest guy in
the loire all time and really have you
ever have you done play-by-play I can't
ride it in Europe this year as a matter
of fact it's very difficult you know and
I mean the analysis no analysis I
probably wouldn't be very good it's
because you have to know when to come in
somebody's telling you and that's the
thing about moas he's reading everything
pre-snap
and the clock is winding down and
there's 10 seconds to go and he's got to
get out for Nance to start calling the
play and he's been he's been damaged
hundred percent Dancing is the perfect
guy cuz he speaks slowly hello friend
you know that whole thing and then Roma
put the thing about Romo to me that's
really great hmm is he so conversational
you sound like you're just hanging out
with a friend at a bar or something like
that and he's in that mid Madden had
that thing that kind of thing he's got
that kind of thing but in a higher pitch
and he starts getting really excited and
it's basically mooch without the hand
movement it's like his hands are tied
down he's like he's gonna sweep to the
right when they leave please hang out
this is fantastic
Tom Brady knows more almost as much as
me wink but that is what's great about
Romo too as you just pointed out there
is that he knows more than most but he's
not wearing it on his sleeve and then
he's everybody at the end he's everybody
that's sitting next to you on the couch
he's everybody that's at the end of the
bar that's not some sort of angry drum
you know some people are like that but
they can't do it on TV right and that's
the thing about Tony rising that I think
is so good as he transitioned
immediately to there and made that
happen and you know Gruden was the guy I
think personally because I like bucket
Aikman I like I think a lot of these
analysts play
by play teams are all great but Gruden
became the guy who's gonna say something
ridiculous people were gonna quote it
and then the network was gonna get
worried what they had to do for damage
control and now Raoul's got this thing
and it's actually a really positive
thing but he is like a soothsayer right
and people like why isn't he coaching
there like like if you can do that yeah
and you can call that out so far in
advance
holy cab Frank Caliendo here on the Rich
Eisen show I want to play one a start
bench cut with Frank Kelly under just
one men what one version of stark bench
got hit it Mike I give you three choices
and you have to start one bench one cut
one yeah okay and these questions this
short bench cut is for Chris Berman yeah
okay and and it's just I'm not even
gonna ask a question normally like who
is the best of all time I'm just gonna
say three names and you have to figure
out start bench cut say what you will
but I did it yeah okay right
for Chris Berman start bench cut Jomon
start Jim Kelly bench Dan Marino cut Jen
you mean I do was I supposed to do it in
a different or supposed to just wait to
hear them and then order they know the
Swami that you need to hear Tony Romo's
in my earpiece and I do me I'm sticking
with it Tommy Tommy will Joe Montana Jim
Kelly but there's no way that Jim Kelly
gets benched by Swami you know what
you're right a bench Joe my dad that's a
great idea
bench Joe Montana start Jim Kelly and
yeah they forgot who the mother in Oh
Marino wasn't able to win a Super Bowl
he still could throw tremendous torque
and I love him because of him I always
have warm hands made me start beds cut
there you know it's fun it's great it
just seemed like there is a little bit
of shefter that came out there according
to my sources and then with the shefter
with the cold becomes Ian Rapoport
that certainly and becoming the wrapper
for it it's very similar very maybe
putting it together a little bit more
but then you get rid of cold and you
become Adam Schefter according to my
sources at this particular time it
appears the NFL is going to start using
robots cyborg officials this came down
from a report from Jerry Jones office
and not just him but his son and every
family member in the Jones family surely
believes and I went to Michigan and I
believe you did as well I did everybody
chapter that's much that could be my
favorite one who works for nine percent
I got one last one for you okay what
would read from Shawshank Redemption say
about Antonio Brown possibly leaving the
Steelers never once and that's gonna be
the filthiest departure I've seen in a
long time Sonny
trying to think a man with that kind of
ability where would he be leaving the
lacks of a quarterback who looks like
wreckit-ralph and on his way to just
about anywhere else truth is you don't
need a Hall of Fame quarterback when you
are Antonio Brown you just need someone
to put it up in the air and you'll make
a deep route work for him throw it far
and a bee will catch it well that was
right there
I'm working on my Kurt Warner too cuz
he's got a cadence that's he really yeah
he's I was but you know he's almost like
a preacher I don't have it yet
and I shouldn't brought it up cuz you
were gonna segue into a commercial or
something but there's I'm gonna do an
event with Curt he's that's charity hard
oh the nicest got but he can't stand
still either if you watch him he [ __ ]
he's a sweater no matter what he's
awesome swag he's just well yeah it's a
so you're working on a current yeah just
because I eat he's becoming more
pronounced I think it's as people you
see the more
and here the more hmm listen this is a
big compliment to the tip to the Sunday
morning show I appreciate it every but
you need them but no you're the only
host that calls out all the problems
that get every day something goes wrong
on every show yes there's a graphic that
goes wrong or something you call it out
you're like in Kurt Warner's jacket on
fire that's that's what you like you
have that happy like all the shows going
to garbage who cares
Kurt will be swinging and the Dallas
Cowboys will understand and Stephen a
Smith calling out the wrong people on
another what I won't even get that right
now trying to say who were even talking
about and then wait should have been
just the Mariucci hands is very G hands
are hopefully those make the internet
just cut me out green-screen me with
only Mariucci hands and robots I don't
know how they open that wide but I'm
ready to go and I could be in casino
right now the guy who plays Ray Liotta
in the chantix commercials that guy
looks almost exactly like him that is
Ray Liotta me by the way the chantix
commercials have unfortunately gone away
where do they go Turkey yeah are you
serious yup quitting cold turkey the
Rayleigh order of chantix commercial is
like manna from heaven really holding
just know you're not who are you doesn't
even use this like I'm ray what's they
write Ray Liotta like every time I've
ever had this up like hi I'm Frank
Caliendo the guy who does all the voices
I am ray and I could knock you out with
the crowbar check out Frank Caliendo on
Twitter and Instagram at Frank Caliendo
Parks Casino February 22nd in
Philadelphia PA and then the next day
February 23rd the Ocean Resort Casino in
Atlantic City New Jersey plug one more
thing podcast hey I didn't have them
tell you about I want to talk
it myself okay what do you got al
Jackson I've been doing a bunch of
podcast together and a group of these
comic book guys - these are two
different ones but Frank pads comic get
you all that information Frank pods dr.
yeah then one over the comic book was
like really at the beginning of it the
Allan Frank's that's pretty cool and
we're gonna get there make it happen
we're gonna make it magical Allan Frank
try to be serious yeah we do we talked
about like serious things okay we try
but it's there's a lot of this stuff
going on a lot of hand movement Frank
you please come back now time man you
have not been banished myself I'm gonna
go hang out with JB Smoove he's one of
my favorites he's so funny great now he
says anything he says I mean just him
going up to Bill Belichick at the at the
Media Day is just fantastic I know
what's this guy doing you know I think
act actually bill gifts are so like
we're you knows who he is oh I think
Bill's a curb fan deep down right I
think he is you know fantastic on curb
you really are I almost I almost tinkled
myself watch that's what we call the mic
drop Frank Caliendo here Matthew
McConaughey not Jerry Jones is Matthew
day honey they're all the same
he's coming up at our three the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience